[Music]
turn it back on the same song you
screwed up man I gotta get back in the
groove specifically the New York groove
give me my Zune no give me the zoom get
it commenced seems a song it's a
degenerate I will not sit here and allow
you to malign Ace Frehley give me the
Sun it's not helping we haven't even
looked over yet me seize the moment you
trying to kill us he said I'd be saving
the universe kill either of you if it
would stop that blinking light the coded
message channel was just been on mantis
a blinking yellow light indicates an
important secret coded message shame on
you man how long this was your job it
was his job
Jax you didn't see the blinking yellow
light did but you said if it was yellow
let it Mellow brown flush it down those
were your orders wasn't talking about
the Cody the message 22 important coded
secret messages that could have been
helpful five hours I've been sitting
five hours we have 22 messages 23
messages oh I keep coming in from nebula
Kimura is alive Danis is taking her to
Titan why aren't you responding why
aren't you responding
are you getting my important coded
secret messages ship coordinates
yeah how do we know this isn't a trap
I'm gonna ask one time who are you
you're the Avengers man Thanos if he
gets all the Infinity stones
he'll wipe out half the universe
everything you know everything you love
it will all be gone just like that well
he's never Ford me yeah he has he's
never fought me twice getting new hammer
he's coming to us I say we take the
fight to him
you guys are screwed
[Applause]
[Music]
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree hi hi I'm Steve Roger
together we can stop France
[Music]
where's your guy
[Music]
dude reimbursed me from the wizard
[Music]